well Afghanistan is an example of the
damage done by rock and we got
distracted from Afghanistan by rock and
now both that in the Pakistan situation
festered I mean the strategic
significance of Afghanistan is that it's
it's interacting with Pakistan in a way
that tends to destabilize Pakistan and
Pakistan does have nuclear weapons so
you would not want a radical group to
you know take charge of Pakistan I don't
think that's on the verge of happening
but it's the it's the reason that that
that region matters to America's
national interest in the most kind of
concrete sense i guess i guess i think
also there's a there i mean a way this
gets back to evolutionary psychology you
know we we have to be mindful of what
our impulses evolved for so the impulse
of retribution why was it designed by
natural selection okay I mean now the
way you see it play out is you know kind
of we've got to get Osama bin Laden or
we've got to get somebody else and
because of something they've done to us
and it often you know you do like to
punish people who do bad things that's
true but you have to remember that that
that the retributive impulse itself was
designed for very different environment
by natural selection a hunter-gatherer
environment in a modern environment it
can go awry I mean the most obvious
example is road rage right i mean you
know driver does something can you
briefly have this impulse to actually
pursue the person and do something you
can get you both killed and there's like
no payoff when you think about it I mean
the purpose of seeking vengeance in the
in the ancestral environment was kind of
show people that you can't be trifled
with it was for the demonstration effect
and you know when you're on a
superhighway there's nobody nobody you
know who's observing you act on your
road rage so that's that's just an
example of
an impulse that can be completely
dysfunctional and I just think too much
of our foreign policy is governed by
impulses like that that that were not
sufficiently critical of